-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We're really excited
to get started
and, now, we're going
to get to the news.
According to a new report
from the Labor Department,
U.S. consumer prices are surging
more than they have in 30 years.
Okay, how much more bad news
is Biden going to get?
[ Laughter ]
At the end of the month,
we're going to find out
the turkey he pardoned was
at the Capitol on January 6th.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A federal judge ruled last night
that former President Trump
cannot shield
White House records
from the House Select Committee
investigating
January's Capitol attack.
Oh, he really wants to, though.
He's acting like a boyfriend
who just had his phone snatched
out of his hand.
"You don't have to hold it
to look at it!
[ Laughter ]
I will just show it to you,
but don't scroll!
[ Laughter ]
Uh, scrolling uses up battery!
During a visit
to the White House on Monday
to celebrate winning
the 2021 NBA Championship,
the Milwaukee Bucks
gave President Biden
a custom jersey
with the number 46 on the back
and he was really excited
because he thought it was
his approval rating.
[ Laughter ]
Twitter yesterday launched
its so-called
Twitter Blue subscription
service in the U.S.,
which will cost
around $3 per month
and allow users to undo tweets
before they post.
Or, for $6 per month,
you can get Twitter Gold,
and they'll just delete
your account entirely.
[ Laughter ]
After missing this week's game,
due to COVID,
Green Bay quarterback
Aaron Rodgers said,
in a new interview,
that he has had
"a lot of time for reflection
while in quarantine."
Unfortunately,
he does all his best thinking
in the shower
and, as you can see...
[ Laughter ]
Television host Dr. Oz is
reportedly considering running
for a senate seat
in Pennsylvania.
What? Who would ever want Dr. Oz
to be their senator?
The only thing crazier would be
wanting Dr. Oz to be
your doctor.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was announced today
that actor Paul Rudd is
People magazine's
Sexiest Man Alive,
reclaiming the title
he first received
in 1938.
[ Laughter ]
A middle school history teacher
in California
was recently removed
after telling students
last month
that Donald Trump
was still president.
Though, for what it's worth,
I bet she's still telling people
she's a teacher.
[ Laughter ]
Rapper Kanye West's
clothing brand Yeezy
settled a lawsuit this week
with the state of California
over shipping delays
and agreed to pay
nearly $1 million,
or, as it's known at Yeezy,
a shirt.
[ Laughter ]
Finally,
according to a new survey,
40% of Americans said
that they strongly approve
of "Sesame Street's" Big Bird
announcing on social media
that he got
a coronavirus vaccine.
They were less comfortable,
though, with hearing
why Oscar needed
the hep C vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!